in some ways city host red.we we could
put today's meeting under the sign of
Aristotle Aristotle interestingly enough
said
excellence is never an accident
it is always a result of high intention
sincere effort and intelligent execution
it represents the wise choice of many
alternatives choice not chance
determines your destiny yeah it's a big
one it's a big one it's a big one of
course because um it it's really a
question of will and this continues to
be an enormous intellectual debate in
both the Natural Sciences and the
humanities what does it mean to have
will do we have free will but I can say
it's also a debate in Kierkegaard
studies because choosing and this was
something that didn't come out in the in
the first conversation is that this
endless possibility that you and pascal
bruckner we're talking about is of
course for Kierkegaard framed in a
subjunctive space philosophically it
means that everything is possible and
the moment you make a choice the moment
you choose you actually ground yourself
elsewhere exactly so the possibilities
vanish now this is you know also a kind
of practical reality you know once
you've decided on the door then those
the two other doors that were
potentially open are no longer open so
so that's simple what's not simple is
what's not at all simple
is whether Kierkegaard's if Google it's
talking about something that is
cognitive and willed in the way that
scientists talk about free will or not I
think not explain this I think because
he's not talking about this kind of
rational highly cognitive choosing among
possibilities he is talking about an
inward reality that has as much to do
with the imagination and feeling with an
emotional state as it has to do with
some intellectualization or cognitive
state there are arguments about this I
mean there are Kierkegaard scholars who
say that there is this kind of high
volitional impulse and Kierkegaard I
choose I decide and others who say no no
it's more complicated than what do you
think I think you you have actually
spent some time with Kierkegaard
scholars yes well no tomorrow tomorrow
I'm giving a lecture at the Kierkegaard
Research Center and that's a conference
there will be as Kierkegaard himself
would say a lot of professors and
assistant professors all working out
details of Kierkegaard's writing and
once you enter the secondary material
you realize that nobody what I can say
is God bless them god bless them exactly
but I think what is interesting from
maybe a lay point of view the
unscholarly unprofitable point of view
is that in Kierkegaard he does not make
reason the top of the hierarchy and
that's important because of course the
history of Western philosophy has been
mind over body intellect or reason
over emotion and cure God really does
away with that and he makes I think I
have a quote quote of mania I'm not the
only one allowed no no okay
this is and the other thing we have to
say and this is a we're not just talking
about Kierkegaard here we're talking
about his pseudonyms as well so I want
to make a distinction
this is climacus by that you mean other
personas sona's that he called in one
place in the point of view of my work as
an author he called them foster sons
that he was the father father and he
denies that one word written by the
pseudonyms was written by him so that's
important to keep in mind so this is
climacus thinking is its superior to
feeling an imagination
this is expounded by a thinker who
himself has neither pathos nor passion
it is didactically expounded that
thinking a superior to irony and humor
and this is didactically expounded by a
thinker who totally lacks all sense of
the comic how coming it's really
wonderful it's really wonderful it's
really yes you quote it I want to pull
okay please let you put I'll do a back
and forth I wrote from the concluding
unscientific PostScript that's it nice
my pseudonymity and pollen enmity has
not had an accidental basis in my person
but an essential basis in the production
itself which for the sake of the lines
of the psychologically very differences
of the individuality poetically required
an indiscriminate nurse with regard to
good and evil broken heartedness and
gaiety despair and overconfidence
suffering and elation and then to give
us a little break here
rights etc what has been really fun
take my word take our one our word we
agree is funny I mean not immediately
but he is funny
what has been written then is mine but
only insofar as I by the means of
audible lines have placed the life view
of the creating poetically actual
individuality in his mouth for my
relation is even more remote than that
of a poet who poeta sizes characters and
yet in the preface is himself there also
that is I am impersonally he immediately
takes away what he's just given us I
don't know where Pascal is but there
that's for you ok
you probably know it by half the scale
support wah that is I am in personally
or personally in the third person as a
souffle as prompter you know under the
theater who has poetically produced the
authors whose preface is in turn are
their productions as their names are
also thus in the period anima Spock J is
not a single word by me I have no
opinion about them except as a third
party no knowledge of their meaning
except as a reader not the remotest
private relation to them since it is
impossible to have that to a doubly
reflected communication my role is a
joint of being the secretary and quite
ironically the dialectically repudiated
reduplicated also or the author or the
other authors but on the other hand I am
very literally and directly the author
of for example the unbuilding discourses
and of every other word in there yeah
exactly
well as well so you're correcting me
because you have
all of this and Danish no this is I
wanted to correct that earlier statement
yeah I have read mostly Kierkegaard in
English but I have checked the Danish I
find it quite hard to read Kierkegaard
in Danish so we are lucky so so I can at
least compare you know it's like I can
have the double X so he's harder to read
in danger for me he is because although
I read Norwegian which is very similar
you know this is 19th century Danish and
I can I mean for example interesting
words like Kierkegaard distinguishes
it's distinguished in English between
existence and actuality and in Danish
actuality I think is visibly head which
we would think of as reality that's
right so no yes and actually there are
more with your German you wouldn't
understand work but anyway no so I want
to disavow any expertise in on the
Danish text I have simply checked back
and forth yeah the statement the
statement on the pseudonyms doesn't
really interest you they do yes in a
particular context well I think first of
all this comes back to the dandy Christ
in a way that you know we can spin a
little further which is that Kierkegaard
also wanted to live his pseudonymity as
a dandy for the residents of Copenhagen
so the idea of the dandy and he uses the
French word flaner the Flener was
incognito for the religious interior is
this making sense to that but it's
making a lot of sense it makes me think
that he's a true precursor of board
laughs in that way well I think that
this this is or compatriots right but
rather but in fact I think what he keeps
saying and what climacus and the
postscript says I am a humorist uh-huh
and then he says but humor is in
incognito in other words you can't look
at a person and know what's going on in
the deep silent faithful interior and
another place you have the night of
faith who looks just like a tax
collector so this is important so the
dandy what is the dandy it's an
aesthetic external being you know in
posturing there's a posturing and the
pseudonymity is part of this posturing
and one irony on top of another
so the maddening but will during
crazy-making part of reading chef Nicola
is that as Pascal was saying it's
completely dialectical but the dialectic
can move so quickly that you think
you're following and then you realize
you've been had you have you have
described my last month's yes well I
mean I I feel like
GTV yes I've really been had and and I
attributed part of this just to growing
old no I think actually we do in some
way become more sophisticated readers as
we get older at least I think I have oh
good but but good because that has not
that has made me only potentially become
more alert to that sense of being had I
mean his you know his majestic God a
treatise which is on the concept
of irony and he talks a lot about
Socrates the first time I read this it's
many many years ago I was about a third
of the way through and suddenly I
realized that he was being ironic about
irony and turning the ironies I was so
annoyed I was so irritated that I threw
the book across the room
and then later reading a biography I
discovered that that is exactly how the
committee who was reading that text felt
they were very annoyed and of course
they gave it to him he was a brilliant
young scholar but they found it to be a
highly irritating text and and
Kierkegaard can be highly irritating and
I think it's important to there's a
little sadism in him in reading him
absolutely
but in him also I think in his relation
to the reader I mean after the beloved
reader yes I'm interested in your
relationship as a writer you're
interested in your reader really
interested in my reader and you address
in in many many of your books no only in
one that one but in this one you I do
immediately address the reader
yes I address the reader it's a it's an
18th cent you know it goes back and and
so many others but you address the
reader and here the reader is addressed
in by Kierkegaard to frustrate him
inside I think so I think so even though
he you know there I think that key
regard is a dialogical writer there is
always an eye on a you I mean Martin
Buber has in a very interesting essay
about about Kierkegaard's you know
relationship to the dow and the reader
is one of those others i think there are
three there's a vageena it was also a
reader especially in the earlier works
there's the reader the beloved reader
and God that's it
with the reader the big one know that
the big other you know it's funny
because I it feels so strange to correct
a writer about his or her own assertion
and I felt that in us oh you're right
and the essays I do address the reader
you know okay ah he got me you're
absolutely right I forgot record
straight I felt no but I felt very
addressed as a reader and you were
speaking to me and really wanting to
know that you were present and I was
wondering you know how much of this had
in in in effect had an effect on you
through Kierkegaard I mean you mentioned
and you know how much effect God
altogether had I I don't think there's
so many novelists today or essayists for
that matter who freely or pleasurably
willfully wanting ly address address the
reader and address the reader and quote
as you do indeed quite often I mean one
here is one of the one of the quotations
from the summer without men she's sane
again and she's in the birders living
room reading a biography of that coy but
passionate genius the Danish philosopher
who has been lurking and up settling and
bewildering her for years and I'm just
curious you know what that relationship
was for you with Kierkegaard who I
believe your paternal grandfather read
greatly that's right and he read with
nearly nothing else but God so is it in
your DNA I you are you are you carrying
around what I don't know this yeah it's
this is my mother's father my mother
told me this he died during the
occupation in Norway in 1943 so I never
knew the man she sort of of course it's
not until I got older did I understand
how strange this was but my mother told
me that her father
only read Kierkegaard and church history
Mamma Mia
and I said to my mother at one point mom
did he read them as oppositional texts
my mother had no idea of curse so I have
no idea if he was establishing some
dialectical reading patterns himself or
or what I have no idea but also when I
was a little girl growing up outside of
Northfield Minnesota across the creek
from where I lived were edna and howard
hong that danish people don't have to
know but they were the translators of
Kierkegaard not only but also of pessoa
didn't they translate pessoa you know
this I do not know okay I think so who
is I think so profound me no I don't
think that they support your case I
don't think so
with a nice story because I think of
pessoa the head of them is I do I think
yes interest anyway the hon yeah we're
we're remote we're translating
Kierkegaard throughout my whole
childhood and I remember going visiting
them as a child and their children and
there was this big stack of papers where
Edna hang was deliberately and laborious
laborious ly translating one work of
Kierkegaard after another so yes
Kierkegaard haunted my childhood and
when I was fifteen I took fear and
trembling off the shelf in my in the
library in my house and read it because
I like the title it was the first time
and the cover penguin now is so yeah yes
and the thing is it was well that's
great that's very rude I think that's
appropriate it is appropriate no it was
the first time that anyone had taken
that I had read a writer who took
seriously the horrifying story about
Abraham and Isaac and so even though I
didn't understand his ironies I clearly
did not understand the philosophical
references I understood
the feeling either Abraham is a criminal
and a monster or there's something else
going on I mean he posits this it's not
Kierkegaard again but it's your Hannes
to cellent you go what do you mean
something I'd love you through to read a
passage I'll read one and then you okay
you read one another okay what I intend
now is to extract from the story of
Abraham it's dialectical element in the
form of problem matter in order to see
how monstrous does something I would
have liked to talk also with with we
just don't have enough go for it paradox
faces a paradox capable of making a
murder into a holy act while pleasing to
God the paradox which gives Isaac back
to Abraham which no thought can grasp
because face begins precisely we're
thinking leaves off and then this little
passage you can read this little passage
and then turn to this little passage
just both of them it will give an idea
well a view of the fifteen-year-old
let's imagine for faith is just this
paradox that the single individual is
higher than the universal though in such
a way be it noted that the movement is
repeated that is that having been in the
universal the single individual now sets
himself apart as the particular above
the universal if that is not faith then
Abraham is done for and faith has never
existed in the world just because it has
always existed Wow Wow so there's
paradox for you the paradox of course is
that he never wants or never argues that
faith is rational or that any proof can
be
there is no proof it is absurd it is an
ultimate pair paradox and to try to turn
it into a rational system as Pascal was
saying very much in the PostScript or
any kind of idealist philosophical
Hegelian apparatus is impossible and
that returns us to the single individual
subjectivity as truth okay here
faith is the highest passion and a human
being many in every generation may not
come that far but none comes further
than there's a break and here you have
but life has tasks enough even for one
who fails to come as far as faith and
when he loves these honestly life won't
be a waste either even if it can never
compare with that of those who had a
sense of the highest and grasped it
pretty incredible oh yeah no he I mean I
think again he writes so beautifully any
writes with such urgency and meaning and
this is why I would like to take a
slight issue with what was said earlier
which is that it is true that
Kierkegaard frames himself continually
and I mean as a father of the pseudonyms
- as a souffle as someone who stands in
the side as an observer but at the same
time the greatest joy and vigor and
living and experience for him was in the
act of writing itself writing is also
lived experience it is subjunctive as he
says it does you know there's all kinds
of possibility in it but I disagree
about the sacrifice the joy he got from
writing was immense now this is not this
is me looking at Kierkegaard not
Kierkegaard self interpretation because
he says there's far too much of the
subjunctive in
you know the if he doesn't say that if
but he says there's far too much of the
subjunctive in me would that I had some
indicative power it's beautiful that's
what Kyle Bruckner was saying fantastic
but you know I do hear a new city a plea
yes a plea a real plea I mean you you as
you're channeling kiss be God but I
think you're talking about you say it
with such vigor and vitality and passion
that I feel that you might be talking
about writing for you yes I think this
is true yes Jesse isn't that his that
writing for him is a need he does not
frame his own productivity as as a
choice he frames it as a need and an
urge and then even more complex he
thinks of himself as God's souffle so
that the pleasure we derived from
reading him is also a pleasure he got by
doing the work yes and that he and this
is very important he feels that he is
being written hmm so he I write but I am
written and and you know before he knows
what the next line is it's there now
this I have to say for me is not at all
framed as a religious experience it's
framed as for me there are moments in
writing any text where the text seems to
be writing itself so obviously
unconscious subliminal forces are at
work and the text just appears or feels
as if it is making itself and that
there's no you know no director
know it this is this is actually there
are many I'm not alone and Kierkegaard
was not alone it's a it's an experience
that recurs Milosz the poet exactly
he said I've often wondered who that
demon was who wrote my poems
and the same experience Nietzsche had a
very very similar experience what was he
writing the gay science maybe he talks
about lightning striking and the words
just appearing before him but you know
in that way it contradicts what Pascal
was saying about him not living yes
that's right defend himself here so it's
kind of crazy I know it's not but I
think in some sense yeah it's different
because what you're saying is that
writing was an activity it actually
wasn't a not doing it's it's lived
experience of a certain kind and just to
reinforce a Pascal for when one moment
to I mean a Kierkegaard did say it's
somewhere in the journals he said you
know the the I'm paraphrasing because I
can't remember the exact quote you know
the great misfortune of my life has been
that I was unable to attach myself to
another to another to another human
being you know so obviously what Pascal
is talking about is also true well yes
matter
so are these flesh matters yeah and and
and so what I'm saying is that maybe I'm
making my own dialectical response to
something that is true with another
truth when I see kotti I I think you're
giving value to something that may it
may seem as with Emily Dickinson or
other writers yes that you know the the
written life is not a full life right
and I I think Dickinson is a great
example and actually I've thought of her
often in relation to character she comes
up naturally and one would imagine I
could think I could think of others and
you know particularly at the library we
have such extraordinary archives of
Virginia Woolf yeah and she's another
one day if you come to New York you you
must see these these archives including
the walking stick with which she went
into the ocean committed suicide
it's anyway why that digression I don't
know but there is there is there is this
moment you know it happens to me all the
time since I'm a bunch of quotations is
a wonderful line of tristram shandy who
says it that digression is a sunshine of
narrative in in either or the judge
writes of following for me the instant
of choice is very serious not so much on
account of the rigorous cogitation
involved in weighing the alternatives
not on account of the multiplicity of
thoughts which attach themselves to
every link in the chain but rather
because there is danger afoot danger
that the next instant it may not be
equally in my power to choose again I
think this is of course is very very
careful Guardian it's also very judge
you know William who I've always found
to be just a little bit of a dull gun
yeah and so you realized that that this
particular voice inside either/or is not
a fully religious voice he's not he
really does not represent Kierkegaard
entirely but the question of choice is
really important and so he's saying the
moment comes I mean the idea of the
moment is huge in here here it's that
it's presents itself and if you miss it
you've missed it you can completely miss
it it's not as if it's necessarily
always there I mean he says there's
somewhere I have another quote about the
self and it's about choosing it's a
wonderful thing because it's a highly
sexual metaphor by the individuals
intercourse with himself this is also
from part two of either/or he
impregnates himself and brings himself
to birth what's quite something
can you read just just just repeat that
I asked uh skeleton right by the
individuals intercourse with himself he
impregnates himself and brings himself
to birth so the idea is that through you
know a self reflective
self-consciousness you know it is a you
know growing up in development either as
a moment comes where we have reflective
self consciousness was a very Hegelian
idea the person can have this dialogue
with him or herself herself to and
through that the self is born so in
either/or there there's a feeling that
the estate's really don't even have
selves yet the self they have they have
they have endless possibility but that
but it's the moment of choosing in this
you know intercourse with yourself this
internal dialogue if you will that a
choice some kind of choice is made again
I don't think it's necessarily fully
conscious or cognitive but some motion
happens and then the self is born I mean
the no but yeah but the anxiety of
missing the moment is yes I mean the the
the choices we have in life not to make
choices
yes yes
I mean it's daunting and I don't think
because you know Pascal was speaking
about the vitality of failure I mean
this is a vitality of failure of your
own life yes yes and I think he went
back and forth you know he he also
regretted his decision not to marry a
lagina well you know it back and forth
back and forth back and forth and
whether to publish under his own name or
not under his own name I mean there's
tremendous back-and-forth in so if you
go and in fact it is also in the
travesties of form that are part of the
Kierkegaard Kierkegaard Ian sued
anonymous of right so the forms are
mirroring the the philosophy in some way
you know there is a when I when I came
here in in early September for the first
time to Copenhagen I met a number of
kakugane specialists and I mean they all
know an enormous amount about
Kierkegaard and I know a very small
amount I want to say that I approached
my my subjects with the euphoria of
ignorance but there was one line and I
very much love in God that has haunted
me you were talking about haunted and I
think we are haunted by lines we carry
them around yeah and there's one that
I've always loved and I wonder how you
would react to it I'd love you to
explain to me what it means for you and
it might then using quotation as a mask
or a shield or a protection I might be
able to understand myself what it means
but it's been with me for a long time I
won't reveal how long I am but for a
long time you got somewhere says more or
less haven't been able to find the line
but it's nearly that because I've read
permutations of it but this is more or
less how I remember it which matters
itself he says it's a goal is to arrive
at immediacy after reflection yes yes
well it's you know the idea of immediacy
I mean there's a beautiful thing in a
fragment that Kierkegaard said says that
language is the ideal and he says
without language man would remain in
immediacy so immediately I think is an
embodied here and now in which
reflection is is impossible the
contradiction is that human beings have
both self reflective abstract
possibilities and this embodied here and
now immediacy and I think it what are
you making this just because he talks
about a contradiction and so I you know
I always see these sort of visual ways
of looking at it and that this inherent
contradiction between the abstract and
and the concrete is Kierkegaard and
philosophy so that human beings who have
reflected and reflected choose a new
form of immediacy which for Kierkegaard
is this inner and silent speechless
domain of faith that's you see I think I
I believe that sounds childlike yes and
in as he says and also interestingly
enough dependent so that that very
difficult kind of a second a secondary
immediacy that's right because in in a
sense we are all going to use foul
language but we are all doomed in some
way because we've we've bitten on the
Apple oh yes I mean in the concept of
anxiety or unk's yeah this is you know
he's trying to relate the individual
experience
of sin guilt and anxiety to the
universal collective notion of original
sin you know the the race as he calls it
to the single individual how do we
arrive at an immediacy after reflection
I mean what is the route how can we how
can we experience and maybe this will be
a subject to speak about with granade
how can we experience the here and now
the tactile the pleasurable well you
know in this yes we are constantly self
reflecting and removing ourselves from
the here and now the tactile the
pleasurable and what actually tastes
good but that's absolutely right and the
fact is you know port 4-7 he said that
he was born reflective which of course
is an exaggeration right but he is
feeling his idea of his own childhood
was that he was hidden I says I had no
immediate he was doomed by as we heard
from Pascal yes in a father but
interestingly enough his father doomed
him and his mother appears nowhere how
do you explain that I think I mean this
is completely speculative but I think
the mother joins the rank of silence and
Kierkegaard that plays a huge role in
other words what we have is endless
numbers of words 7,000 pages in the
journals alone and I think it's all
turning around these silences which he
says is double silence for him is both
the ineffability you know the ineffable
in faith and the demonic so the mother
occupies I think this place of silence
of the unspeakable its mothers of so
interesting in that I mean mothers are
very in well we were but mothers because
they they we learned
speak from them we we we learned to
speak from them but also I think it's
also the the fact that we are in Sun and
then there's no separation
there's no abstraction no symbolic cut
to use a little French Theory in there
was so much to say in in slowly closing
not too quickly I know time is running
out but what can we do in the summer
without men you have this line in his
journals kiss who guard writes that
dread is an attraction and he is right
dread is a lure and I could feel a tug
but why what had I actually seen or
heard that created the mild but definite
pull in me perception is never passive
we are own we are not only receivers of
the world we also actively produce it
this there is a hallucinatory quality to
all perceptions and illusions are easy
to create even you dear reader can
easily persuaded that a rubber arm is
your own by charming by a charming
neurologist with a few tricks either up
his sleeves or in the pockets of his
white coat so this about dread
yes being a--you're well I think he had
this little passage of course I realized
after I published this book that but not
everybody understood all the ironies but
anyway that's that's a cure Guardian
position because once you enter into the
realm of irony you have no idea who's
going to receive it as ironic and who's
going to receive it I remain is partly a
private language always always you know
this it's a risk I really we both live
in in the United States we do
and I actually in the same part of New
York Brooklyn and what was I going to
say well I know you go I know I just
remembered i but go yeah no I just I
think that this did that in the concept
of anxiety which is an maddening
dizzying crazy making book it really is
I think he's enacting in the prose what
the reader is supposed to feel and in
that text you feel this attraction you
know repulsion and the gestural or the
mental images that Kierkegaard conjures
in the reader I think are very important
to what we think of as the philosophical
meanings this is really not an image
about Saudi philosophy yes yes and he
has this idea of the mimikar yeah which
is like mime so I think the mental
images that the reader creates and of
course they'll be different depending on
the reader are vital to the experience
of reading but you know in living
thinking looking you have this essay
which I really I really love called on
reading and I've read so many essays on
reading and I must compliment you on
that on that one in particular
you say philosophy usually does not stay
with me in pictures but in words
although I have formed images for
Kierkegaard for example because he is a
philosopher novelist a thinker
storyteller I see Victor amita the
pseudonymous editor of either/or with
his hatchet as he smashes the pieces of
furniture in which too many spirits
manuscripts have been hidden yes so he
really he's there he's here that's right
and I think you know for in
the academic work on Kierkegaard this is
often ignored you know that sort of
novels are a little embarrassing or that
that there's you know what is he really
saying well part of what I think
Kierkegaard and this his sued anonymous
perspectival beings are getting at is
beyond the abstract concept and it's
living in these pictures these mental
pictures that he's working very hard as
a philosopher slash novelist and he's
left traces he's you know walking
philosopher in Copenhagen he's a
peripatetic yeah you you and we have all
these you know that this this great
library here has some of the most
extraordinary probably the most
extraordinary archive and there's so
many drawings of Kierkegaard as a
wanderer as a walker yes I know what I
was going to say about Brooklyn but it
wasn't about him it was about America
and irony all right it's not a good
subject but it is a subject but it you
know I've lived there for three decades
and I still cannot get over the fact
when it's a hyper generalization but
when I was gonna say countrymen but I'm
from no country but when Americans want
to be ironic they will go like that
seems to me to be the most
extraordinarily undoing of irony of
course of course it's it's I mean it's
the end
Sylla Firth is that he cool of course of
course and it's it's I remember after
September 11th everyone was announcing
the death of irony and it was a horrible
moment in New York as you know but the I
that the thought that people should
announce publicly that a form of double
consciousness that as far as I'm
concerned
necessary to existing yes should be
banned from American culture was so
stupid that you know I really felt
annoyed I write an irritated polemical
essay just about everyday in my head I
mean I can't do that many essays but you
know the really angry letter to the
editor same words no I mean I think this
is just this is naivete about what human
beings are today and lack of confidence
and perhaps the result of a very short
history at least on the part of the
white people who who started the United
States of America but God who God gives
you confidence is an understanding
that's right I mean in a way reading
Kierkegaard helps us understand the
complexity of multiple languages
Kierkegaard is an antidote to all simple
explanations about what it means to be
human
thank you very much it was a great
ending but and I think in a way I maybe
overstaying my welcome but I will I will
I will deal with Lisa later when she
tells me my goodness you went over time
but you you're so interested theory in
ambivalence and I think ambivalence in
the context of what you were talking
about really is interesting and I could
read a long quotation from you on
ambivalence but rather than do that and
it seems to me that ambivalence as it
fits both in your novelistic and essay
istic work somehow has its origin
maybe not origin but has an inflection
that
yes I think ambivalence is good but it's
actually ambiguity and there are two
different things so ambivalence is a
kind of going back and forth ambiguity
is when you really cannot identify what
your right coherence can cannot
eliminate ambiguity
however ambiguity is not quite one thing
not quite the other it won't fit into
the pigeonhole the neat box a window
frame the encyclopedia
it is a formless object or feeling that
can't be placed ambiguity asks where is
the border between this and that and
then it goes on to that's right many
other things so I think that I am
interested not in mush not an ambiguity
as mush as an intellectual concept but I
am interested in applying not one model
to the same object but multiple models
and out of that I think you can get what
I call focused zones of ambiguity now
there are two people Simone de Beauvoir
and Maurice merleau-ponty who talk about
ambiguity philosophical ambiguity a very
interesting way who have had some
influence on me not up when he was
interested in science as well the
Natural Sciences and neurology as I am
and so I think ambiguity is a rich not
an impoverished concept that's it thank
you you're welcome
you